PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Have you ever wanted
to know how health
care companies deal
with large amount of data
coming from multiple different
sources?
Well, I've been
really curious how
our insurance claims, lab
reports, and other data
is put to use.
So today, I invited Amol
Kher, VP of engineering
from Vida Health, a really
cool health care startup
creating a personalized
experience for patients.
Welcome, Amol, and thanks
for joining us today.
AMOL KHER: Thanks, Priyanka,
looking forward to this chat.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Awesome So
tell us more about Vida Health.
AMOL KHER: Yeah, so
if I also describe
Vida in one sentence
or one line,
it would be that we are an
additional health, virtual care
company.
And we connect both
mind and body programs
into a single platform.
A lot of companies
that you see out
are often treating
patients for one condition.
And our platform
actually supports
multiple different conditions.
So it really helps
people when they
can go to this one
single place and get
different kinds of treatment
on a single platform.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, awesome.
So it sounds like there
are three different types
of customers.
There are the individuals like
us, who may need the help.
And then there are health
plans, and then you
have the employers,
who are helping.
So let's double click
on that a little bit.
What are the challenges
you actually set out
to solve for these
three customers?
AMOL KHER: So as
you can see, we have
a lot of different kinds
of data that's coming in.
And we have to connect
all of that stuff
together in a seamless manner.
And we have to host
this, and we have
services that are
mobile focused,
but there are services that
are for web on the backend.
And so it's a pretty
interesting challenge.
And I'm glad that
we've consolidated
everything on Google now.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Awesome, so ease of use
is definitely one that you're
pointing out as the reason
to choose Google Cloud.
Are there any others?
AMOL KHER: Yeah,
as I looked at--
when we were evaluating
Google Cloud,
really, there were
three big areas
that came to me as reasons why
consolidating in GCP was great.
One was just the cost reduction,
because after consolidating
everything, it's just
one single place where
you can drive efficiency.
And we've already seen
somewhere around, like,
50% reduction in cost just
by bringing everything
in one place.
You can optimize, fine
tune different things.
The other thing I
would say it was more
around developer productivity,
because now engineers
don't have to worry
about where to deploy,
and, kind of, keep that
cognitive overload much
more lower because it's one
single place that they know
how to look at and monitor.
So they are happy.
And if they are happy, they're
more productive, right?
And then the final
piece, I would say,
is that we had already made a
lot of investments in BigQuery
in AI and ML.
So combining all these
data sources in one place
and bringing even things
like Google Workspace
has proven to be very
effective for us too.
And it opened up a lot of
interesting new product ideas
that we were not thinking of
before, or not possible before.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: What are
some of the challenges you're
solving with machine
learning and data analytics?
AMOL KHER: We are trying to--
we have three or four
different areas of investment
in machine learning and data--
data science today.
Part of the area
that we focus on
is how do we make
our providers--
we internally call it making
a provider superhuman,
so building tools and
assistive technology that
can help providers become
much more efficient at how
they do their jobs.
As an example, using notetaking,
automatic notetaking--
so because we have the audio
and video conversation that's
going on, part of the
job after a consult
is for someone to actually write
down the notes for the patient,
or what if, like, using
NLP and speech-to-text,
we are able to just take
down those notes for you.
So that's one area where we
reduce the amount of burden
on the provider so
that way they can treat
more patients in some ways.
And then another area where
we've tried to help providers
is also how can we make their
case, get them more patients,
without burdening them too much.
So as an example, depending
on the severity and acuity
of the patient, how can
we surface those patients
much quickly to our providers.
And maybe there's others who
are doing already very well.
They don't need
that much attention.
How do you prioritize
that caseload?
So those are a couple
of applications
that we've seen on
the provider side
where machine learning has
been very useful in servicing
this information much more
quickly to our providers.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: From
our conversation earlier,
I do recall Vidapedia, which
is another major recommendation
platform that you built
with data from Workspace
and BigQuery.
Now, what is it, and
how does it work?
AMOL KHER: Yeah,
well, first of all,
let me explain what
Vidapedia is, even
without machine learning.
So it's a set of protocols.
It's-- basically, you can think
of them as Google Docs that
have been written that help our
providers and our clinicians
follow a protocol when
certain things happen.
Over time, our
medical organization,
you know, Mike Scahill,
he sort of created
a corpus of almost 150, 200
protocols that help people
know what is the right level--
what is the right thing to do
and what's the right care to
give in a particular situation.
And now, as you can
imagine, no human
is able to store 200 different
sort of protocols in their head
at the same time.
And it becomes a data
access problem, right?
How do you quickly get access
to this sort of information
at high speed?
And so what Vidapedia
Recommendation System does
on machine learning
is actually we've
kind of indexed all
those documents,
and then we look at
what patients are--
what is the patient provider
interaction that's going on,
and then surface the
right protocol for a given
interaction.
So if, during the course
of this chat interaction,
the machine learning
model detects
that this triggers a
particular protocol,
then it surfaces that to the
provider during the session
or even after the session.
And so then what
happens is the provider
is able to give the right
care to the patient.
And so from our point
of view, the provider
becomes more efficient,
at the same time
increasing the level
of quality of the care
that they're providing.
So the team is pretty
excited about that.
And we wouldn't have
been able to do this
if we were not able to
connect what the Google Doc
protocols looked like
from Google Workspace,
take that data, and index
it and store it in BigQuery,
and then be able to
build machine learning
tools on top of that, right?
And so you can see pretty
quickly, by going to Google,
one of the things we've
been able to nicely connect
is the Google Workspace
data that our providers
use to our actual service,
which is the machine learning
algorithms, and build a
product that's, in my opinion,
something pretty unique.
That-- when we set
out to move to Google,
we had not even
thought about this.
But now that it's there,
it just makes applications
like this actually
possible for us.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Yeah, that is so amazing
to hear because it is one of
those unique aspects of using
Google Cloud, because
Workspace data is right there,
and you can just
put it into BigQuery
and start to do stuff with it.
Now, obviously,
this whole workflow
is pretty data intensive.
And this is an
architecture show, so
let's dive into the details.
What does the data
pipeline flow look like?
And what are the data
sources involved?
And how is it making its
way through the tools
to making it useful
in these machine
learning use cases that
you just talked about?
AMOL KHER: So we ingest
data from a variety
of different sources, all
the way at the beginning,
where our health plans might
send us eligibility files,
or they might send us claims
data that tell us a little bit
more about the member.
Then the members themselves will
often bring their own devices
into the system.
So for instance, they
might have a Fitbit,
and they might connect
that with the Vida app.
So now you're getting to see
the steps that they're taking,
or the weight, or
whatever log-- whatever
they are logging in that.
For diabetes patients, sometimes
we ship out glucometers.
And so then you get to see
their sugar readings and stuff
like that.
So all of data is
getting ingested.
Some of it is real-time.
Some of it is batched.
And it's-- we're collecting all
of this stuff from different.
Then, even on the provider
side, the providers
are conducting consults,
and they're taking notes
for those consults, right?
So that's another piece
of data that gets ingested
into all of this stuff.
And the goal of
this data platform,
is at the end of the
day, help derive insights
and make decisions on
top of that, right?
And so our goal was to
create a system that's
seamless, where everything
gets stored in one place,
like BigQuery, and
then drive in sets,
build tools on top of that.
So it's not just BigQuery data,
which is somewhat unstructured,
but also structured
data and relational data
that we get from
Postgres and MySQL.
All of that ultimately
lands in BigQuery
for us, and then applications
get built on top of that,
right?
So our analysts work on
tools, visualization tools,
like Data Studio and Looker,
and our data scientists
build on top of
the BigQuery data
to build machine learning
models and connect that
to our actual services.
One of the things that
we've recently gotten use,
are exploring, is how
can we use Vertex AI
for quickly building these
models and deploying them.
In one of our recent
hackathons, one
of the most impressive
things about this tool
was that even, like, non--
I would say-- machine
learning engineers
are able to quickly
use Vertex AI to try
out and experiment and see
if that might be useful.
So I'm pretty excited about
the seamless integration
of the ingest as well as the
analysis engine that we're
building on top of that.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That is so cool
to hear because we just launched
it recently, right, at I/O.
And we have an entire
series of Vertex AI videos
that I've been working on.
And we will link those below.
So thanks for the mention
on Vertex AI and how easy
it has made to use the--
to apply machine learning
to any sort of data, and
make the steps easier
and accessible to everybody.
Now, I'm curious about
the transformations.
So you talked about where
you're storing the data.
and a lot about
machine learning.
There must be some sort of
transformations happening.
What are you using for
data transformation?
AMOL KHER: Yeah, today we have--
in the past, we
have been writing
a lot of custom ETL pipelines.
We've learned that managing
them, monitoring them, keeping
them stable and running
has been a challenge.
And being a small team,
just like we try and find
ways to do managed
services on Google,
we've tried to explore
what are other tools
available out there.
And we've settled on dbt
as the transformation tool
that we plan to currently
use for transforming some
of this data as we move it
from one system to another,
or get it ready for
analysis and stuff.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
So there's a lot happening.
Obviously, there's data
ingestion, then transformation,
and then there's machine
learning on top of that.
How do you manage all of
this stuff in a pipeline?
How do you orchestrate
this pipeline?
AMOL KHER: Well,
I mean, this case,
the answer is pretty simple.
I think we just use Cloud
Composer for orchestrating
the pipeline,
scheduling all of this,
ingest, processing data, and
running all of that stuff.
So, again, having
these tools ready
and be seamlessly working
well with BigQuery
is beneficial for us.
And I think the team has
sort of taken that up
and implemented them.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: All right.
So when it comes to
health care, it's
important to address the
elephant in the room, obviously
security, right?
Let's talk a little bit
about high-level security
requirements that
you have to look
for in designing this system.
AMOL KHER: You're right.
I don't actually think of it as
even the elephant in the room.
It's just, like, always there.
And one of the
reasons that I forgot
to mention when we
initially talked about what
was the advantage
of going to Google,
is that in the old
system that we had,
we had these two
different Cloud providers
that we were working on.
And one of the fundamental
things with security
is what is your surface area.
And we've had a lot of data
flowing between one system
to the other.
That creates-- that opens us up
for higher surface area, right?
Someone can--
something can go wrong
and people can get access to it.
So because the patient data that
we work on is fairly sensitive,
we have to be extremely
careful of protecting it.
The privacy laws around
this are pretty stringent.
So actually moving to Google has
been beneficial in that sense,
because, first of all, we are
a small company, as a startup,
and so I always tell
everyone I'd rather just
use Google as my shield.
We have thousands of engineers
at Google who are thinking--
living and breathing, constantly
thinking about security
and how to secure the
Google Cloud environment.
And so just being part
of that whole ecosystem
helps us immensely,
where we don't
have to worry about
our own security thing
as long as we follow the best
practices that Google lays out
for us.
And I think we are also,
sort of, combining that
with the Google
Workspace side of stuff,
where you can enable things
like data loss protection.
We can mask PII data.
All of these things just become
instantly available to us,
and we don't have to spend
a lot of our mental capacity
to think and evaluate
what we need to do.
It also helps us with
our customer site
because people are
more likely to believe
when we tell them,
like, hey, we've
used and turned on whatever
Google is doing in this space.
Also with our health
plans, for instance,
they are often looking
for a vote of confidence.
They are kind of
saying, hey, what
Cloud vendor are you using?
And when you tell them
that you're on Google,
they're often pretty
satisfied with the fact that--
if it's a big company like
that is sort of taking care
of the security, we kind of--
I call it bump drafting behind
a big company like that.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
No, it's extremely
helpful because a
lot of the times,
we think that going
with multicloud
or having things in
hybrid cloud is good.
But then, especially
in this case,
when it comes to security, it's
a little bit like you said.
Reducing your surface
area of attack
is the most important
thing to think about.
Now, we talked a lot about
the data analytics and machine
learning architecture.
I want to pivot a
tiny bit and learn
more about the application
architecture itself.
Now, how is the web app set
up, the compute, the database?
I assume it's all
normal, standard stuff.
But I would love to
hear about that as well.
AMOL KHER: Because we did this
migration fairly recently--
we moved from a different
cloud vendor to Google--
we were able to work with
a Google partner, SADA
and really use some of the
best practices that there are--
and modern practices that
are available to us, right?
And so it's not very surprising.
It's like a standard, I would
say, a three-tier architecture.
You have load balancers at
the front, just deployed in
and Kubernetes Engine, Google
Kubernetes Engine, and then
a middle, sort
of, API layer that
returns a whole bunch
of requests response.
And at the end you, have
a Postgres database.
And so architecturally,
it's not that complex.
Simple is good.
It's easy to scale,
especially on Google.
So, for me, that's
been the great thing.
Even the database is like
moved over to not-- like,
our own custom sort
of Postgres thing.
We're on GCS Postgres.
And that way,
scaling of database,
which used to be a big
discussion point and debate,
it just becomes a few
clicks of a button,
and you can now vertically
scale a database if you want.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So, well,
you mentioned a little bit
about migration.
How did you go about doing that?
AMOL KHER: So I work with
the Google support team
that I have--
who I work with pretty closely.
And we kind of knew that--
I had made up my mind that we
wanted to consolidate our cloud
system into one place.
And Google was a choice.
And so with Will,
we kind of evaluated
a few different partners that
could help us do the migration,
ended up choosing SADA for
a few different reasons.
I think they are pretty
well known in the industry.
Part of the major
migration plan here
was around how do we
transfer all of the data that
was in the other
cloud system, have
minimum downtime
for our customers,
and then also how do
we make sure we set up
this new system in a much more
modern and easy to deploy way
so that our engineers,
going forward,
can take ownership
of that system
and be able to continuously
deploy the system.
We probably work for about a
quarter, quarter and a half
to come up with the entire plan.
And when they
wrote some of the--
they helped us write on the
code around terraform scripts
that can help us
deploy to Google.
And then on the actual
day of migration,
they also are on-hand to
make sure we're orchestrating
the most, sort of, together, so
shutting down the whole system,
migrating data, and
turning on the new system.
So it was a pretty
exciting time.
But I'm so glad that it
went without a hitch.
And now we're pretty
happy with this system.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: It
sounds so cool to hear
the back story of
the migration, right,
because we just talked about
the architecture, which
is the current architecture.
And then-- and
then when you hear
the migration story and
all that goes into it,
and teams like SADA and
the Google Cloud team,
and your team combined
together, like,
bring the whole thing to life.
This is pretty amazing to hear.
Now what's next for you guys?
How are you planning to augment
this existing architecture?
And what else is
underway for Vida?
AMOL KHER: Actually,
now the fun part
starts, from my point of view,
because it's all in one place.
And my call for the
team is now let's
double down even more, make more
use of more managed services
that Google offers.
And in particular, I'm
very excited about a couple
of areas, which is
the Google Health Care
API and the FHIR-related
capabilities
that Google is
invested in, right?
So historically, FHIR
has not been a very--
it has not had a
lot of traction.
It's been increasing
little by little.
But we've heard over the
last year, year and a half,
things have moved quite
a bit in that space.
And just like we are
storing all this information
about medical data in one-- in
our own proprietary formats,
we want to now start using
Google's FHIR storage
as well to start
storing the data
so that it's easier to exchange
this sort of information
with other networks
outside of Vida.
So the classic example is,
like, you go to a doctor.
They refer you to another
doctor for some other reason.
You would expect that your
data gets securely and clearly
transferred over from one
place so that the other doctor
doesn't have to ask you
the same thing again,
or trying to understand
what you are trying to--
what are they trying to treat.
And so the same thing,
same challenges,
are coming for us as well.
So if we are treating
someone with a condition
that we are not--
that we currently don't support,
and we want to refer them out
to someone else, we want to be
able to create a system where
our data just gets very
seamlessly transferred over
to another doctor, like maybe
an inpatient experience as well.
So this is what I'm
pretty excited about,
because Google Health Care
APIs and the FHIR capabilities
that Google is
building on are just
things like where applications
can be built on top of.
And I don't have to worry
about the protocol layer,
and how is it stored,
and all that fun stuff.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
Just store the data, let
the API do the thing,
and just access the
API to do the thing.
AMOL KHER: Yeah.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, thanks, Amol.
It was awesome to
have you on the show.
AMOL KHER: Well, thanks again
for inviting me as well.
And it was great to
showcase how we've
built Vida on top of Google.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
we learned a lot today,
how to set up a data pipeline
for health care systems,
and, the most amazing part,
how beautifully the Google
Workspace data can be combined
with BigQuery to create
a recommendations engine.
Well, if you are interested
in learning more,
there's an entire blog
linked below that dives
into the details of how
Vida Health and the team
at our implementation
partner, SADA,
brought this
architecture to life.
Want to see more real life
architecture like this?
Subscribe to get notified.